Speaker 1: Let's continue hearing from
our audience. We take calls via discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord. You
can join the waiting lobby. And we have a
number of really great people who want to
chat because I tried to go to him earlier
and it failed. Let's try going back to Sal from
Malden. Sal, welcome. Are you equipped to speak?
Speaker 2: Yes. David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can smell welcome.
Speaker 2: Oh, awesome. I'm so sorry about
earlier. I've been a fan watching since 2018. Big,
big fan. Thank you. I just had a question.
More on relating on are there current topics?
Are there current topics within the
left that you feel that are not as
talked about or are considered new fields
that the left hasn't really tackled on?
Speaker 1: Not so much. I mean, I think there's a
couple of issues that I would like to see the left
become, sort of like revise the default view and
become more informed about, I would say GMO food
and new nuclear power would be two areas where
I think the left has been reflexively and I'm
talking about the left broadly, but not everybody
within the left. Anti-GMO, even though there's no
evidence GMO foods are bad for you simply by
virtue of being GMO and reflexively against
nuclear power on the basis of the dangers posed
by 40 year old technology, which is not what would
be built today. I'm not going around saying Let's
eat as many GMOs as possible, or let's just switch
100% to nuclear power. I'm not saying either, but
sometimes in conversations with some on the left,
they're like, Oh, GMOs are bad, nuclear power is
bad, and it's unsafe. And I just. Those are two
areas I've researched somewhat extensively. And
I just think a lot of the default reactions from
people on the left are wrong on those issues.
Speaker 2: Okay. Yeah, definitely on the edge.
GMOs is something that I've seen somewhat divided.
I've actually seen I'm actually very pro GMO,
but I've actually agreed with people on the
right on some of these issues when it comes to
using GMOs to whether they see it more as an
economics, a benefit in the economics, I see it
more as just being more efficient with food, but I
find it at GMOs is something that the left hasn't
really, I guess, taken a. Deep, deep dove into.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't know that it's like
the number one issue that everyone's like, I
got to learn more about GMOs. I think there's
just a lot of people who are like, they
must be bad. I don't know. It sounds bad.
Genetically modified can't possibly be good.
Speaker 2: Yes. And off the top of my head,
I've heard that in some countries
in Europe, some GMOs are banned.
Speaker 1: So they're banned or bad.
Speaker 2: I guess band. Oh I believe
was. I may be misquoting but.
Is that a general view outside
the United States that GMOs should be banned?
Speaker 1: I don't know enough about attitudes
towards GMOs outside the U.S., so I wouldn't be
able to say it's really an empirical question.
I just don't have the answer offhand,
but it would be interesting to see.
Speaker 2: Oh, okay. Yeah. And I just
had one quick question, please. So.
I need a lawyer for my leis because this
lawsuit is is just taking a huge toll. Do
you have any recommendations for any lawyers?
Speaker 1: I don't. I know that your machines
are under threat from Mike Pillow, but
he's going to be distracted being RNC
chair soon. So I think your lathe is going
to be okay. All right, Salford, thank you.
Speaker 2: So much for.
Speaker 1: The call. Very nicely executed.
I appreciate that. We have so many folks here who
want to chat today. Let's try Lily from Nebraska.
Lily from Nebraska, welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Hello? Can you hear me? Yes. All right,
cool. I've been a long time listener, but this
is my first time calling in. Well, welcome.
So, in regards to you, what you what you have
stated previously about how it's difficult for
many people in the U.S. to leave the country if
if the country were to be too far gone. Yeah. In
terms of I don't know, a better way to say that.
But I actually have found a very good way for
people in high school to to potentially leave the
country for college. Like, I've experienced a very
easy process with moving to Canada for university,
and it's actually pretty affordable. And so,
I mean, it's just it's the same thing as the US
college application process. Yeah. A little bit
more like you need to apply through immigration.
But with that I think a whole bunch of like people
who are under 18 years old can consider that.
Speaker 1: If that's useful for people of a
certain age. I have family going to school in
Canada as U.S. citizens and. Yes. And there is
a path. It's not super easy to just be like, I
want to move to Canada now. I'm going to work
in Canada forever. But there is a path where if
you get into school in Canada, then once you're
there you can be authorized to work. And then
if you work in Canada for a period of time,
then you're authorized to actually get permanent
status. And I don't know if it's like permanent
residency or citizenship, but that's a
great path for people of a certain age.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I know. That obviously does not
apply to people who are already past that age.
Right. But yeah, in my specific circumstance, I'm
planning on attending the University of Alberta
for the next four years. Okay. And I also found
out that people who are attending college in in
in Canada actually are eligible for the Canadian
rates for university, for graduate school. And
that's fantastic. That is significantly cheaper
than anywhere that you can go for the U.S..
Speaker 1: Yes. It is.
Speaker 3: Typically interesting, as.
Speaker 1: Typically.
Speaker 3: True. Yeah. There is no such
thing as in-state or out-of-state or in province
or out of province and candidates at the same
rate for everyone. And so, yeah, I just wanted
to get that out to people who are planning or
who are looking for ways to get out of the U.S..
Speaker 1: All right, Lily, thank you very much
for the suggestion.
Speaker 3: Yeah,
thank you. And I'll see you later.
Speaker 1: All right. Lily from Nebraska,
thank you very, very much.